we're standing in the rain forests of
the world exhibit at the California
Academy of Sciences which is an exhibit
we've just created where we'll bring
several rainforest habitats more around
the world together in one place with
this habitat that we're in is there's a
big greenhouse if you will inside the
California Academy of Sciences in Golden
Gate Park and it's divided vertically in
half one half being devoted to new world
rainforests central South America the
other vertical half of the rainforest is
for galleries where we look at the
rainforests of the Amazon Madagascar
Borneo and Costa Rica and so you come
into this exhibit and you get a little
flavor for what rainforests are like all
around the world plants animals
butterflies birds snakes fishes reptiles
just of a snapshot in one place when you
think of rainforests you think of heat
humidity and plants and trees and so
those are the things that are the main
challenges if you will and so what we
did was set up a system here with
natural daylight artificial lights
humidity and temperature control that we
can create the conditions of a real rain
forest here in San Francisco
we have a pretty elaborate HVAC system
on here and a misting system you can see
going off behind me and so those are all
controlled by a building management
system where we're monitoring light
levels humidity and temperature and
controlling them to the point that we
want them and so what we've done here is
we've tried to create the sort of
essence of rain forest where we're
bringing real plants some fabricated
trees some real animals birds
butterflies and so on and mixing all
these things up and creating what is an
essence of rainforest the pool here in
the forest is actually it's bigger than
it seems it's about a hundred thousand
gallons and it's about probably ten feet
deep as a tunnel through the middle of
it and so we've chosen the species of
fish that will live in that size and
shape pool and will live with each other
hopefully without eating too many of
each other but it's always a challenge
from time
time has we have a lot of big predatory
fish and sometimes the big predatory
fish eat the smaller non predatory
fishes but you have to manage that by
choosing them and choosing fishes the
right size and keeping the big fish
really well fed the secret when you
create a habitat like this is really
doing your homework to begin with so if
you avoid making a lot of done mistakes
early you come up with a plan that that
you've researched and that works and so
I think here we chose a system where we
could create conditions that suited the
animals and plants we've chosen and we
sort of adhere to that plan and now you
see the result of it where it's all
coming together and so I think it's not
a very ad hoc process where you just
bring a collection of animals and plants
together and see what happens
you have to really research it talk to
others that have done it and in
formulate a plan and then do your best
to follow the plan and we've been I
think we had a good plan because things
are really working out very well for us
here
you